les très petites entreprises regroupe
plus de 80 mille salariés dans le
département pour les informer sur leurs
droits la cgt des yvelines a organisé ce
vendredi soir à trappes une soirée
portes ouvertes sur les tpe
au programme de la réunion des débats
sur les conditions de travail les
salaires ou encore les formations
la cgt a l'ambition d'être le syndicat
de tous les salariés dans toute leur
diversité
un des salariés des très petites
entreprises donc moins de 11 salariés
sans représentants du personnel dans
l'entreprise sont très nombreux dans des
tas de secteurs différents
donc c'est bien sûr un enjeu de pouvoir
les toucher les organiser discuter avec
eux de ce qu'ils vivent au travail et de
comment on peut améliorer les choses
dans leur travail pour présenter leur
action le syndicat projeté un film sur
les tpe dans la salle des dizaines de
pochette d'information également été
remises à cette occasion on a mis dans
dance et pochette d'accueil
notre répertoire du département donc
avec ce qu'on fait dans les yvelines des
modèles de lettres des coordonnées
utiles
on a aussi des tracts spécifique aux tpe
ou par ou par métier et puis ça annonce
un petit peu nos dates sur le
département
au total une vingtaine de salariés à
participer à l'événement la prochaine
réunion de la cgt se tiendra le 6 juin
24 rue jean jaurès à trappes
le rendez-vous concernera les salariés
du secteur des hôtels des cafés et des
restaurants